500 videos thousands of facts shared and
almost 10 million subscribers thank you
for that all in the name of battling
misinformation
and yet i've let some pieces of
misinformation slip off my tongue as
well i'm human too doctors make mistakes
and here i've compiled a list of every
time that i said something medically
inaccurate on this channel huge thanks
to those who did point it out
[Music]
i am not a fan of vaping i miss my hair
it still has chemicals you're still
inhaling chemicals some of the flavors
have propylene glycol in them which has
been known to cause a condition called
popcorn mug that's my mistake i updated
it in the description of that video but
it's important to point out propylene
glycol is not the chemical uh that
causes popcorn lung it's actually
diacetyl that causes popcorn lung small
distinction but important distinction we
want to be accurate on the channel when
i do these types of responding to
comment videos i'm answering from the
top of my head the huge majority of the
time unless you see me look it up on
screen doctors do make mistakes
especially mixing up chemical names
that's on me they just dump a ton of
ingredients active ingredients into
these things and people don't realize
that there's tylenol in some of them
acetaminophen in others like dayquil
there's caffeine in there all right
that's my mistake but i'm gonna say a
bud here because there might not be
caffeine in daiquil there's other
stimulants in there that are used as
decongestants but there's also caffeine
found in other products might all
complete bayer back in body which is
aspirin and caffeine excedrin for
migraines has caffeine in it because
they theorize enlarged blood vessels
cause the headache and by shrinking the
size of them by giving you caffeine
which is an upper they can shrink the
size of them therefore reduce some of
that pain so there's a lot of products
out there that do have caffeine dequel
unfortunately is not one of them but it
is stimulating remember that because a
lot of the medications that use
decongestants also have an uh ability to
raise your blood pressure and i
oftentimes have to warn my pr my
patients who have cardiac conditions of
that important point big pharma's first
adderall meeting meth but for children
so mad it's bad
but it's accurate one of the main active
ingredients in adderall is
methamphetamine my mistake no
methamphetamine in adderall there is
amphetamine and dextro dextroamphetamine
very similar compounds but there is no
methamphetamine there were a lot of
comments about that and the reason why i
sympathize with those comments is
because people get unfairly judged for
using adderall if they actually need it
and that's really unfair because if you
have a medical condition there's a
treatment out there that works for you
and people are judging you because it is
called meth because it has
methamphetamine in it which is the same
compound that's not fair the dosing is
different indications are different and
remember every substance that we take
into our bodies reacts differently
within each individual meaning that if
you have a medical condition that
warrants taking small doses of
methamphetamine and if someone judges
you for that that's that's messed up if
you can't sneeze look at a source of
bright light
if you can't sneeze do do people walk
around wanting to sneeze yeah mike if
someone is on the verge it's like you're
on the verge of a sneeze and you're
trying to ignite the sneeze yeah look at
a bright light and then what happens it
would make you sneeze
that's
what there's got to be more well there
is more to it and thank god i looked it
up the reality is there exists something
known as the photic sneeze reflex where
you look at a bright light and it causes
you to sneeze a lot of times this is
just a mild reflex but sometimes it can
be quite serious there's actually
theories as to why this happens not even
a well-known mechanism they theorize
that it's cranial nerve five and ten
that are involved in creating this
reflex it's cool that they have a
mechanism but at the same time very
weird that it's only a proposed
mechanism not even a well-proven one
didn't you also get egg on your face
because you looked at lead and sneezed
later in this video yeah yeah that's
true like
oh my god it worked right it's not like
this
oh alcohol
is this rubbing alcohol you still feel
nauseous actually no
thanks all of that is fake news i'm
sorry the alcohol inhalation for
nausea actually has some evidence i
looked it up found out it's actually
true they used actually non-pregnant
patients in an emergency room setting
that had mild to moderate nausea and
they had them sniff alcohol like one to
two centimeters below their nose and
like half an hour later 50 improved and
obviously there were different studies
with different outcomes but it seems
like a really simple way with low chance
of adverse effects to try and treat
someone's nausea without using
medications because like the most
commonly used medication that we have
for nausea is called a densitron and it
actually has serious complications if
it's used in the wrong patient meaning
that if you already have some cardiac
arrhythmia it can make it become worse
so much so that it could be fatal and
again that shouldn't scare you away from
taking that medication if you're truly
having terrible nausea vomiting it's
just a known side effect sniffing a
little alcohol literally expelling it
one to two centimeters of your nose very
low chance of adverse side effects in my
opinion i have a lot of upset stomachs
and a lot of 7-ups oh this is our
grandma bobby video we have to say rest
in peace to her she unfortunately lost
her life after we filmed this video not
directly after but sometime had passed
so sending best wishes to her family and
making sure that they know that she's in
our thoughts first of all seven alpha
contains cat feet misinformation dr mike
7up does not contain caffeine i mix this
up with mountain dew 7up is actually
caffeine free does not make it fine by
the way like it's still not an ideal
thing to drink nor does it contain
enough ginger to actually warrant the
potential anti-nausea effects that
ginger has on our bodies
what you're talking about is
something i mentioned a lot it's called
ptg ptg is post traumatic growth
it's a person who've gone through
something horrible some kind of trauma
like war
like cancer family member who had cancer
and they come out after this traumatic
episode and they grow as a person they
become better they find an outlet for
their struggle i've never heard that
term
there's no it's not in literature it's
not something that you would find i came
up with in my own mind but i've also now
saw other people mention it i saw a
reaction to this video by a trained
mental health professional and they were
critiqueful of that statement of mine
and i can unders understand why what i
was thinking to myself in my head as i
was talking about it was that
post-traumatic growth was not in the
literature that was being taught to me
as a medical student as a resident as a
doctor really meaning that a lot of the
information that we're being presented
with when it came to mental health was
negative meaning pathologic everything
that can go wrong there was no research
articles being presented to us about
positive psychology like post-traumatic
growth in fact i wasn't even aware that
there was a term in medical literature
known as post-traumatic growth it's
something that i just kind of came to in
my own thinking later looking back at it
there was plenty of researchers who were
doing this and doing it quite well
started reading books on the subject
learning more and more about it i did
not create it i don't take credit for
post-traumatic growth it's very easy to
say okay here's what's wrong you have
depression you have anxiety and we need
to fix that we need to get you back to
zero but what about helping that person
not just go from zero but also into the
positive state of mind because a person
shouldn't just be bland they shouldn't
just experience no emotions it should be
a balanced spectrum of negative emotions
that don't take them so far that they
can't control it and also positive
emotions that don't take them to a state
of mania where they can't control their
spending their other urges and so on did
you know putting a pudding putting they
didn't even get the g in there putting a
cabbage leaf on the breast take a frozen
cabbage leaf and stuff it into your bra
over the infection
what infection these things don't even
specify that's a really good point what
if the the pregnant patient has an hiv
infection they think that the cabbage
will help this will do wonders in
treating mastitis okay now we've least
localized infection that's an infection
of the nipple area this cold cabbage
leaf does the work of a cold compress on
the inflamed breast and provides relief
here's the cabbage leaf thing because i
looked it up people said there is some
research on proving that cabbage leaves
do work and to my surprise there are
some research articles on this i don't
know who conducted that research and
some of them are of decent quality um
and they did show that there was some
relief from discomfort breast hardness
breast tenderness etc but i still think
my point holds true that if you put a
warm compress or a cold compress that'll
do very similarly the same thing without
the risk of potentially adding on to
that infection foods have bacterias on
them mold on them and that mold can get
into already infected area so to me it's
dicey to recommend this as a treatment
to patients and still largely
unnecessary despite the fact that i will
admit there is a few articles out there
supporting its use and a possible aim
for the organic sort to reduce possible
pesticide contamination all right well
that's an important point here because
cucumbers are part of this like dirty
group of vegetables that really need a
lot of cleaning and if you're going to
be eating the peel you're going to want
to wash them very thoroughly and going
organic this is kind of the mistake i
made here does not mean pesticide free
it actually means that they can use
pesticides but they have to come from
natural sources and as we've grown to
know natural does not mean safe or not
toxic because nature out there is very
much toxic
show a spider
oh i remember this with with the pam
video about fake or real diseases we're
gonna keep this covered here for you
because this triggered in a lot of
people trypophobia which isn't
necessarily recognized by the medical
community as a true specific phobia but
it's the fear of small holes gathered or
clustered closely together and this
image got people very nervous i had to
change this thumbnail very quickly
because the amount of comments i got
were staggering please tell me this is a
neurosurgeon doing this not like foreman
it's forming oh my god these they're all
neurosurgeons infectious disease
specialists family medicine doctors okay
i can get offended here and i still am
allowed to because they act like they do
everything they give no credit to
nursing staff cma staff respiratory
techs just so many individuals in a
hospital that work to make it function
and actually patients have probably more
contact time with those specialties and
individuals than they do even with the
doctors but a lot of you left comments
saying that wow dr mike's not a true
house md fan because foreman is actually
a neurosurgeon
i looked up the house md wiki didn't
even know that existed and foreman
actually did his residency in neurology
so still not a neurosurgeon and then
applied to be a fellow under dr house
which i guess is like an infectious
disease or diagnostician fellowship
still not a neurosurgery resident still
not a neurosurgery fellow none of the
above he shouldn't be doing this it's
unethical so while i will take the loss
by saying that he's not anything related
to neurology he's still not a
neurosurgeon it's really unfortunate
that i have to knock out idubbbz after
having so much respect for him but know
that idubbbz i'm only knocking you out
because of the tremendous respect i have
ah messed up here okay i didn't knock
out items only because i didn't know my
man has a chin of granite steel i don't
know what's an indestructible substance
like whatever kryptonite he has i didn't
have it in my knuckles and i need to get
back to training but i will say i
definitely hit harder than butterfly
kisses come on idubbbz sorry doctor mike
you don't have knockout power your
punches are like little butterfly kisses
in his hands right now
rolling that rock right here just like
that again over him
those eyed up on stable legs after
taking some of these shots
and huge congrats to idubbbz and anissa
and creator clash for raising 1.3
million dollars for charity
obviously i come down hard on natural
remedies but here's a list of natural
remedies that actually work click here
to check that out as always stay happy
and help
[Music]